here is Denver Colorado's top fine
dining establishment the Buckhorn
[Music]
Exchange it tells you everything you
need to know about the
city
guns
whiskey
Taxidermy yes this is Denver in a
nutshell God bless the West
[Music]
[Applause]
okay okay the city is actually nothing
like
this it's mostly like
[Music]
this Sunshine even in the
winter Stoners and non- Stoners uniting
in their celebration of The Great
Outdoors
[Music]
enjoy go deep
[Applause]
[Music]
Park oh hi I didn't see you there
normally at this part of the program i'
would be walking through the front door
of a startup but on today's episode we
cannot do that for this startup wants to
remain secret because its nerds are
making a smart
[Music]
gun that Navy SEAL you see before you is
holding a gun made by
biofire its very very big claim is that
it's the first company to make a smart
gun that actually works that's right
James Bond style fingerprint and facial
Rec
recognition the gun only fires if the
right person is holding it it know
somebody's holding on to
it but no matter how much he pulls the
trigger nothing's going to happen
because the system is not
unlocked the person who started biofire
is Kai Kuper he's all of 25 years old
and has been working on making this gun
for 10 years a project he started
shortly after the Aurora theater
shooting at the time this is like the
worst mass shooting in history
and happened right just down the road
here from where I grew
up I was fortunate enough to not have to
think about gun violence or gun deaths
and that was really my first sort of
encounter with the topic right I was
like just starting to grow up just
starting to think about these kind of
topics as a
15-year-old and really started to think
about how how could we do something
about
this I started thinking about this
concept of smka by no means am I the
first person to think about this
obviously and it's been science fiction
forever but nobody had ever really built
a working smart guy okay so you're 15
yeah and instead of doing some policy
that you're kind of you're inspired yeah
I was never a policy person right like
I'm an engineer I've been forced to
become a little bit more of one you know
over the last 10 years but no I was an
engineer I I was a a socially awkward
nerd a Bonafide nerd who clenched his
nerd bonafides by getting an award at
the very prestigious Intel international
science and engineering fair so okay so
for people who don't know I mean this is
like no joke it's this is like
yes thousands of the world's smartest
kid to top the year I went it was the
top 1500 out of over 8 million people
competed across the year yeah like this
is the the top of the top it's yeah it's
as high as it gets I think for the
science fair
world at the time I was mostly an
electrical engineer and I could sort of
fake my way through some mechanical
engineering so built a pretty good
electrical system and a really
mechanical system sort of slapped them
together into this kind of gun-shaped
object not an actual firearm in any way
I wasn't allowed to bring a gun to the
science fair quite
obviously like I was very surprised by
all this you know i' done a lot of
science for project
before three4 of the time people didn't
believe that I'd actually built them
they thought my parents had did them I
mean this is the nicest way possible Dad
I'm I'm sorry but um my dad needs help
like turning his iPad on the thing it's
low
and after 10 years of toil Kai is
understandably proud that his business
finally has a product to sell cool after
to you today we've got one of our uh
Mark 2 prototypes uh pre-production
units of the uh Mars smart gun so as
soon as I start to interact with it um
I'm going to see those white lights the
white lights basically mean that it's
active it sees that somebody's picked it
up but it hasn't recognize the user yet
so it's still locked to set up the gun
you register your face and fingerprints
on this device in less than a minute or
you can also add and delete other
users if you're not
registered nothing
fingerprints are very well optimized
very commercially mature you don't need
a lot of processing power to run them
appropriately facial recognition is is a
Cutting Edge biometric which means it
requires orders of magnitude more
processing power so where previously we
were able to just use like little
microcontrollers and things like that to
do fingerprints we've had to basically
build an entire computer hardened for
the system you know that works inside of
a gun to be able to run facial
recognition at the speeds that our
customers
[Music]
demand I've shot guns before but I'm far
from a gun
enthusiast in many ways on biof Fire's
target audience a dad who wants to keep
his family safe but who also thinks
having a gun at home probably ends up
more dangerous than good still old gun
or new I needed a few pointers I would
try to lean forward like just like Lean
Like lean into it a little bit a yeah
there you
go okay and again the target's like less
than 10 ft away so um you don't need to
worry too much about aiming I'll point
that out sorry the target is like 100
plus yard
and Ashley is about to you know do a
marksman level short of shot here am I
cool to try
yep woo there you
go it's still had more kick than I
thought I was going to it's all good it
kicks and from my experience it
[Music]
works the question is will it
sell several companies have tried and
failed to make a smart gun because it's
really hard to do and not just because
you're mixing sensitive Electronics with
regular explosions okay so you've chosen
to do a startup doing this incredibly
hard technology and then to wait into
like a second amendment sort of issue
right so this is like nightmare yeah
keeps it interesting that as Kai has a
talent for doing is putting the
controversy mildly proun folks hate
these things because they fear that one
day the government will use the
existence of a working smart gun to ban
the dumb ones even flirting with smart
guns leads to death threats and
financial risks one of the reasons biofi
investors prefer to stay Anonymous and
plenty of anti-gun folks don't like them
because you know they're guns for his
part Kai's not interested in mandating
or even advertising his product biofire
he says is just here to provide choices
and maybe save lives the key thing that
we are trying to solve which I think we
could completely solve is is uh children
and teenagers getting access to
firearms firearms are now the leading
cause of death for children teenagers in
America they surpass motor vehicle
accidents uh for the first time in
2020 I've never talked to a gun owner
who wanted their kid to find their gun
and so we think that by Building
Technology that you know basically works
with the gun owner to enforce what
they're already looking to do allows us
to really actually address that portion
of of the of the challenge of basically
gun deaths in
America the final version of biof Fire's
gun arrived in a April with this funky
sci-fi look it's definitely more Halo
than Red Dead Redemption but how well it
will sell is anyone's guess we want to
look modern and futuristic and and a
little different than everything else
that's on the market obviously when I
saw that one I was it does have a little
sci-fi thing going on again we don't
want it to look too normal but we don't
want it to look like only you know
something that a Sci-Fi n would like
like like the Cyber truck or so yeah I
was trying to not say
[Music]
that
have you ever had that thing man where
you're hanging out on a bench and
looking at the clouds and you're like
there's a
dragon there's a
turtle hey there's a
jellyfish wait I think that jellyfish
has a camera on it I think that
jellyfish is watching me it is it is
there is a suspected Chinese spy balloon
that's been hovering over the northern
us yes there was that moment that the
world looked transfixed Upon Our visitor
from China what China didn't know though
was that America has its own Super
high-tech balloon program able to be
launched by Hoodie wearing dudes
wherever they can find
parking we saw a path to finally make
the stratosphere and stratospheric
balloons viable this super old
technology that has never really been
able to become broadly
applicable the makers of this fancy
balloon Andrew and Jared work here at
Urban Sky the basic idea is that high
altitude balloons can be used to capture
lots of imagery of the world filling the
stratosphere sized gap between other
aerial options you got drones at one
layer and planes at one layer and then
there's just like huge jump up to
satellites and there's just kind of like
nothing in between yeah we I mean we say
it sometimes like we we somewhat view
ourselves as like the SpaceX of the
stratosphere Urban Sky Images might look
a lot like satellite imagery but they're
much much more detailed and can be taken
more cheaply and frequently tracking
things like wildfires the effects of
climate change and all manner of human
activity you know you can see cars you
can see features on roofs you can see
Landscaping you can see light poost uh
power lines so in case people are
worried it's not like Espionage cannot
see a person right yeah you cannot see a
person we have no intention of doing
that
yeah both men have serious history with
balloons they used to work for worldview
which makes massive stratospheric
balloons and also takes pictures with
them the problem though is that the
balloons are expensive and take many
hours and a ton of people to launch
Urban sky is trying to make ballooning
quick and easy our big bet was that
sensors and components would miniaturize
to the point that we could make very
very powerful highresolution Imaging
systems and a very lightweight package I
know the first time I describe this
company to someone they're going to be
like how do they control this thing it's
just going to fall in in some City on
somebody's head you know I mean it's
pretty obvious concern yeah well to I
mean at a high level we do control it so
it's like it's not a balloon that's just
going to fall out of the sky and go uh
somewhere random we know pretty
precisely exactly what altitude our
balloon will float at then you can think
of it like we're in like the currents of
the ocean like they're fairly uniform
that we're moving in a general direction
when we get to a float altitude when
it's time to come down Mission Control
sends a signal and the balloon gently
deflates nice easy
Landing system's in great
condition all right this is the balloon
making operation welcome to the balloon
manufacturing
yeah yes they're willing to show us
their balloons just not tell us what
they're made of it's like a plastic or
yeah yeah we could speak to it a little
bit it's some of it's a secret in terms
of what it is but can I touch it yeah
yeah go for it it feels light which it
turns out is important for a balloon and
everything attached to it so this is the
money maker this is the money maker this
is one of the money makers so we have
several different Imaging payloads that
we operate uh this entire thing you see
here weighs less than six lbs this is a
wildfire monitoring system so the guts
of this is basically a thermal infrared
camera so NASA and the air force uh have
funded this system and we think it'll
have a ton of value for doing early
detection of wildfires and in true
Colorado nature-loving fashion they also
want to make it reusable it was always a
little bit heartbreaking to see this
literal mountain of thousands of pounds
of plastic get put in a dumpster what's
the most you've reused one three times
for one balloon so yeah we can get
several reuses out of a balloon
eventually we want to get to the
Paradigm where these systems are
reusable the way something like a
parachute is reusable where you can use
the same system hundreds of times okay
let's see this thing in its natural
habitat time for a field
trip so we found this kind of like empty
little carve out of area but you guys
could just be on the side of the road or
it's safe and legal to park we can
launch from there yeah you kind of just
need whatever's as big as the truck
right right ready for
fill
[Music]
all right here we
go is there something you say Up Up and
Away oh
[Music]
wow is it going to inflate like and look
like a big teardrop or it is so it's
only about 10% full right right now okay
so that gas is expanding as it gets
higher and higher in the oh right
atmosphere gets less and less
dense as the balloon went up and up like
a memory from childhood I was
dangerously close to feeling something
intimate about a piece of inflated
[Music]
plastic I don't know probably just the
Mountain
Air
[Music]
if you're in Denver itself it's all beer
and pot shops and dumb
[Music]
Bridges tossing some dogs and joggers
and you get the
idea of course what you want to do is
get to the Great
[Music]
Outdoors I mean this might as well be me
heading to
Mordor it's weird and beautiful and it's
everywhere in
Colorado Colorado is the kind of place
where you can put on some waiters hop in
a stream and run into a rocket
scientist meet Joe laurenti the CEO of
rocket engine maker Ursa
Major we are on the Big Thompson
River pretty in the middle of nowhere as
far as Colorado towns
go this is pretty normal Colorado
fishing experience that you drive these
Rivers find a spot to pull off the road
and go find fish yeah and what are we
going to try to catch what's our goal
some trout all right all right man I'm
excited we just want to cast this out
and kind of let the let the river take
it but otherwise the Bob staying on top
yeah just pull it out like that exactly
because you want that yellow line to go
all the way to the
end so just do that a couple more times
yeah and don't be afraid to have too
much line just don't want to hit
you there you go that's
perfect don't lie to me
Joe this is 30 minutes from the office
so you don't get that in a lot of other
places
yeah is it like changing as all that
Californians are coming
and I I don't tend to notice that they
come help us build rocket engines so
yeah all right watch your face all
[Music]
right no it's also low risk with these
small trout flies cuz the hook is like
centimet long yeah I'd still feel bad if
I hooked a c
that
Ursa Major does its work here in a
suburb of Denver where it can fire its
big loud
engines where we're looking right now is
our that's two Hadley engines facing us
so we'll see fire coming right at us
okay see some fire
cool that'll loosen up some
seals the world today is full of Rocket
startups and each one is trying to make
their own rockets and their own rocket
engines but as many of them have
learned engines blow up okay you just
saw bright
flash it's what makes building Rockets
So
Hard Ursa would like them to consider a
new idea don't bother making engines buy
them from us like I've noticed though
all these rocket companies I go to there
is this the engine is like the yeah it's
like the sexiest part it's like the yeah
it's like we're doing something big and
important and everybody wants to make
their own engine even though it causes
all this suffering and financial ruin um
how do you how do you sort of convince
people to get off that a piece of it is
kind of breaking down that that romantic
[Applause]
notion there are a few reasons companies
buy engines from us the the most common
or the easiest sale is uh the make
versus buy decision if a company's just
starting they need an engine we have
engin available that's almost a
no-brainer we can save them 5 years tens
or hundreds of millions of
dollars the other opportunity is if
there's been a failure if if you might
have maybe it's your first flight maybe
it's your 50th flight if you have a
launch failure and you're facing down
another 5year engine development
campaign to fix that right cuz if
there's a failure you have to shut down
figure out what we're Run come back and
prove that the fix
works it's almost an easier story to say
there's a known reliable engine on the
the market that we're switching to
versus diving back into why did our
engine
fail is there a fear that the people who
were going to make it have already kind
of made it and and they're already
making their own engines and you sort of
need these newcomer rocket companies
that hadn't already made that commitment
and maybe it's too late I think I would
have that fear if NASA and the Air Force
and the space force and every commercial
company we're saying today we are
completely happy with how we're getting
to orbit and capacity is completely met
but that's absolutely not the
case the company is off to a good start
with big orders from several startups
plus some deals with the Air Force they
sell a relatively small rocket engine
Hadley for just under a million dollar
their next size up Ripley is still in
development this is a turbo pump
assembly for Ripley can we for a moment
talk nerd out on turbo pumps yes it's
true I an engine geek but objectively
Ursa is one of those badass companies
with badass Hardware the turbo pump
really Powers the engine it's it's the
heart of the engine really you're taking
things from one extreme to another so
you're taking minus 300 degree liquid
oxygen you're combusting it to thousands
of degrees you're using that to drive a
turbine that needs to go from zero to
tens of thousands of RPMs but like even
SpaceX for years didn't build its own
turbo pump they had a company build it
we we've got an incredible turbo
Machinery Team all made by badass
people I'm a big fan of paragliding
skydiving and base jumping like
propulsion technician Margo
vinga I love the way this company
operates I think it's so it makes so
much
sense the way that we exist allows other
companies to
exist it's almost funny that it hasn't
happened sooner because you're looking
at companies like Pratt and Whitney or
Rolls-Royce they're making engines
Boeing's not making their own engines
that would be crazy that's time
consuming that's the hard part you know
you know technology overall is
notoriously kind of skewed male and in
my experience aerospace companies are
it's like 9 to1 yeah is that weird or is
that changing or there's definitely
significantly more women here than I'm
used to working with yeah it's really
nice actually cuz I don't feel like I'm
like in a fish Pole or some kind of zoo
animal and of course for practical
reasons it has to be
here this facility is pretty interesting
because most of the places I've been if
you think about SpaceX or blue origin as
examples you're building in engines in
California or Washington and then you're
going all the way to Texas to do most of
the tests you don't have this kind of
feedback it just it slows everything
down we we just saw I mean you can do
everything in in in just like a few
hundred yards from each other yeah it's
very
unique we definitely could not fire
engines like you saw today in Los
Angeles because in
Colorado you can be as loud as you
[Applause]
like
holy that was like a lot better than
anything I've seen a long time it's a
unique experience out here holy cow man
I mean that was so freaking loud that
like cuz even when I've seen Laos you're
a mile away and that's like 200 yard
yeah that was that was that was
cool and with that
I did Colorado the way you're supposed
to guns on the way in glorious fire
spigot on the way
out Adam Klein and golden shoulders
please play us
off from Denver
Colorado and I was all
alone alone alone all
alone all
alone and I made a huge mistake I moved
away from Denver
[Music]
Colorado and I don't know why I don't
know
why away from Denver
Colorado I was
all
[Music]